Cái là giọt mại sai số giãn tiếp kênh hợp với chup tiếp,
học sinh lắm với mà không làm cái gì này được mơ đặt tảm nhiệm đi.
Sai, câu này thì người ta cho thông số của quán gường,
và thông số thời gian có sai số lối.
Đó là ta cho một cái câu tụi linh hệ,
câu tụi này thì là sao số giãn tiếp,
đúng không?
Đúng không?
Vì là kết quả nó, nó tụi thơ.
Thì em muốn viết với cái quả nó có nước thời, gờ này.
Rửa ra sai số ổ thiê bệnh thì người ta chung bình.
Rồi trung mình nhẹn có dùng đúng không?
Tất ngại em lấy các là trung mình ngọt rồi.
Đúng không?
Hà nhìn Hà trung mình chí do,
Tây trung mình, bình phương.
Đúng không?
Em tính không thể là ai.
Hà nhìn Hà trung mình là thời này.
Bởi vì chí tạm.
Đúng không?
Nhưng mà nhớ đồ, cho nó thời vì đơn vị ở đây là mẹ.
Thì để làm bởi chẳng chỉ mấy tạm.
Mì đi mẹ, nó sẽ là không phởi, bởi chíng gám.
Đúng không?
Hà, chí mà nhau, chí dơ bình phương.
Đây là hồi bụng không bố nhé.
Hà, mình có lấy cơ thằng thằng ở đâu rồi.
Láu là nó thằng chương bình.
Bởi mời là, nó ngon nhiều đẹp.
Hà chíng phơi bởi tạm tạm tạm.
Bởi bởi tạm.
Đúng không?
Hà, hà chà.
Thì bây giờ mình mới đồ, mình biết không có xa số tí đồ, rất thời.
Sai số tí đối, mình không thương như này thì xấu tí đối, mình không có xa.
Mình không muốn ở tây mình phương rồi.
Tây xa số tí đối của gờ.
Sẽ bằng xa số tí đối của f, cộng giới hai lần.
Xa số tí đối của tây.
Đúng không?
Nhìn nghiệm vụ của chúng ta muốn với đổi xa số tí em thêm nữa.
Thì rất là chí cộn tí em thêm đến em.
Nhanh tắc ở đây.
Sẽ nó bọ mạnh nhiều đồ, đó.
Thì đi bây giờ mình nhìn nhá mình biết là này.
Sa số tí đối của gờ nó xa hói lên tắc ở chiều trung bình.
Nó xa hói lên tắc em.
Chói ăn trung bình.
Cậu hai lần đến ở tây.
Chió tây trung bình nhé, hói.
Thì mình gọi một tình gờ nó, để trình nhìn thấy lấy đời xong.
Lúng ra, lấy mết thài lấy đời xong.
Nào, anh thấy số tài lấy em.
Nên tắc em là bằng một, đúng không?
Xí cho a trung bình là bệm xí tám.
Ở hiểu không?
Nhiều tây là không phải không năm.
Chió a a trung bình, a chió tây trung bình cho khởi bụng không muốn.
Và nhanh mạnh nhiều em.
Nhiều mình có trung bình.
Nếu a trung bình của tính, a chí ở trên này này.
Chính phởi bệm bệm bệm bệm tám.
Ở hiệm thì ra được thằng lên tăng hòa.
Tòa.
Lên tăng hòa xong a không phải 2 năm bốn.
Mà trên rồi.
Để đây có cái thường số tốt thì viết được gà rồi.
Bằng cơ chung bình này.
Cậm chú lên tăng hòa.
Ở.
Thì ở cây phía xong 1, giản tiêu trò.
Nhiều tình gần cạnh cho vào phía thài số giản tiêu.
Tòa.